scp-682 vs scp-170  can the ultimate molecular superglue pin  the hard-to-destroy reptile down for  good the scp-170 glue was laced onto a  series of metal chains with the hope of  confining rather than executing the  monster the tissue sample was promising  and things proceeded from there 682 was  sedated and wrapped with chains which  were then connected to the ground  initially when 682 woke up it thrashed  around and tried to escape however its  attempts were futile but before  researchers could start patting  themselves on the back 682 began to grow  until it reached such a size that the  chains simply popped off the leading  theory as to how this worked wasn't that  it hadn't technically grown but  increased the distance between its  particles shattering the molecular bond  created by scp-170